hello Visa how are you sir I I'm so
amazed and baffled I can't believe I'm
I'm talking to the one and only New York
Times best-selling authors
I love you oh this is the best Visa
um I'm gonna cut your segment down to 30
seconds oh no you have a you have to dig
yourself out of a hole now for an hour
no no I I accept that you have uh
acknowledged uh sona's achievements and
her Fame and I will do my best to not
annoy you or get in the way of this
interview
okay okay okay let's continue so now
before we move on you know what I love
about Kona fan yeah is that there's that
old saying everyone's a comedian Kona
fan is proving that worldwide everyone
is a comedian yes and they're quite good
yeah they are very good we've learned it
from you man we learned it from you
where are you where are you coming from
Visa I'm coming from Finland oh my God
you know the place yes yes yes Finland
Finland uh very close to my heart I I
visited Finland years ago during a tense
political election uh I played a pivotal
role and uh it was it was one of the
joys of my life was going to Finland the
people were amazing uh and we shot uh
the first real travel episode that we
ever did and I had so much fun that it
it made me determined to go and do more
of them so I have a great fondness for
for Finland where do you do you live in
Helsinki no no no I I live in uh
basically in the very eastern border of
Finland in a small town called
love very good very good
and do you like to drink in say it again
I see I can't say it if you keep saying
oh sorry I'm trying to learn from him
but you keep saying it to to and now I'm
I'm sorry I can't go on
I can't I mean I mean I'll never do
another podcast again
I'm so glad to be part of your last
podcast this is an honor I thought it
was an honor before this but now it's
the last one oh this is the very last
one because I I can't learn how to say
it
but do you know what what's the other
reason this might be your last podcast
yes because because I I didn't get uh a
command to boost the record button on
the audio so I have no idea oh I have no
idea if you can hit record for us now in
the meantime oh so nothing's been
recorded no no we're recording we're
we're recording his site it's just for
his side of the conversation I see I see
so you should hit record right now
um because that's what you need to do to
record things
oh oh really yes
well I'm learning I'm learning from that
I'm learning from the best again yes yes
I heard you're you're so good with this
Tech stuff I am I'm what we call a tech
wizard yes yes yes
so so Visa here's what I remember fondly
about your country people like to drink
uh korskenkova this is the thing I I
basically I'm calling you about now
because you say it's almost perfectly
but just a little bit wrong you it's
costly
no
you're saying the r in the beginning but
it's only at the end of course
okay how about this perfect I [ __ ]
came close enough
when discussing an unusual drink from
Finland
yes yes this is what the but that was a
time in my life I'll never get back
again
yeah but I was so happy when you said it
you know you it's so nice you're so fond
of Finland I am you know you won the
election you want the election guess
what uh I will tell you
uh something that you should know I have
two stickers on the back of my car only
two one is for the Theodore uh Roosevelt
uh National Park and the other sticker
is the sticker for Finland those are the
only two really yes it's the one that's
just f-i-n and you've you guys have seen
it's on the back of my yeah it's on the
back of my pickup and those are the
wrong yes yeah the oval I have that
those are the only two stickers and I
have many people say to me I don't
understand really the only sticker I
have on my cards
yeah now it's very good now you can now
you can uh no but if you if you uh see
me in Los Angeles and you look at the
back of my car you will see that I am
representing my fondness for Finland
wherever I go and I have no other
country represented on the back of my
car that's a true story with the peacock
with the peacock the what not with that
not with not with the Tesla you you have
it in the pickup the pickup oh the
pickup
visa to be fair I do keep a urine cup
yeah yeah in all of my cars because she
wants to pull over and ask to use a
restroom those things are filthy
constantly you know what I have to
urinate I go down at night I go down
into my garage and get in my car and I
go in the urine cup or as you like to
say peacock or as you say in Finland
yeah but that's what we do in Finland
too we pee in a cup we don't have
toilets